is it even possible to wake up at 5am
feeling glorious
heck yes it is it is currently 5 45 as
i'm filming this and i'm super excited
to share this video with you today
because i'm going to share with you some
of the things that i do to be able to
help me to wake up between 4 30 and 5
a.m on a regular basis so if you've ever
tried to wake up at 5am and have failed
or have just tried to wake up earlier in
general consider this your call to give
it another try but this time with a few
changes that will ensure that you will
wake up every day without feeling a hot
miserable mess but before we begin if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss when i post a new video and
if you don't like it by all means thumbs
it down but please give me some feedback
in the comments so that i know what to
work on all right let's get started
before we can even address your morning
routine we first have to talk about your
nighttime routine because the key to
having a productive 5am routine
productive is to have an even better
nighttime routine the night before
because waking up early is not about
sleep deprivation empowering through
that actually the research is totally
clear that sleep deprivation can have
profound negative effects on your health
and your lifespan but besides that how
productive are you really being if your
brain is total mush because you didn't
sleep the night before so having an
awesome nighttime routine is imperative
this will ensure that you wake up
feeling well rested and ready to
dominate the day what does this amazing
nighttime routine look like you might
ask i got you covered
use science to your advantage like many
awesome built-in features your body has
it's your circadian rhythm that's
responsible for your sleep wake cycles
but through the exposure to blue light
through lighting in your home tv screens
computers and phones a hormone called
melatonin is suppressed and that's
really a bummer because that hormone is
responsible for making you sleepy so
what you're going to do is be like a
chicken we have chickens that roam
around free during the day but around
sundown they wander back into their coop
all on their own so what you're going to
do is take our chicken's advice around
sunset start turning off your devices
and have your phones set to
automatically change to night mode so
that they can cut down on blue light
start closing your curtains and if you
don't have blackout curtains i highly
recommend them this was something that i
tried when i worked night shift and it
really helped me out because i lived in
an area that was just highly lit so if
you live in a city maybe then perhaps
try blackout curtains and also just take
this time to tidy your home so that you
don't wake up feeling stressed and
anxious first thing in the morning when
you wake up because we have kids and our
nighttime routine involves getting them
ready for bed we usually start around
7pm so that most days we are in bed by
nine so find a time that works for you
but especially in the beginning give
yourself more time than you think you
need and if your phone is your alarm
have an automatic do not disturb so that
you do not get woken up with texts or
phone calls during the night and put
your phone to bed and i don't mean in
your bed have it across the room or
maybe even in another room to force you
to get out of the bed when it rings
use technology to your advantage so i
mentioned that our nighttime routine
begins around 7 pm and we actually have
smart bulbs that are scheduled to dim to
a warm light at 7 00 pm and this not
only means that our home automatically
becomes darker but it also sends a cue
ah it's bedtime and then in the morning
time they're set to 100 bright daylight
and especially on days when i really
don't want to get up it sends a message
to my eyeballs see that yessie see it it
is time to get up another thing that we
do is we set the thermostat to a lower
temperature at night and this actually
lowers your core temperature it kind of
tells your body to wind down our
daughter has hypersensitivity especially
to sounds and so she has a sound machine
that helps her sleep really well at
night but for me my go-to is ear plugs
because if my husband snores not only
does that mean that i can sleep but he
can sleep as well because i'm not like
elbowing him the entire night the ones
that i have are silicone and washable
and they really are help to me and this
was also one of those things that i kind
of picked up once i worked night shift
because if you've ever worked night
shift you know that you have to have
like impeccable habits to be able to get
the sleep that you need and you
definitely don't have to get any of
these things but if you have them use
them to your advantage because it will
help kind of create an ambience that
will promote sleep
recently i witnessed and assisted in a
traumatic head-on collision between a
dump truck and another vehicle and i
have worked in icu for years i've been
in emergency situations but i had never
been in the scene of an accident before
and it left me shocked for several days
i really struggled to fall asleep
without seeing or hearing those images
in my brain and to sleep without
dreaming about it all night long and so
i have been very diligent to practice
gratitude every night before bed and it
may sound so silly it may sound like a
pointless waste of time but i assure you
for me it feels like it's almost like
i'm priming my brain priming my
subconscious to think of positive
thoughts and to perceive positive
thoughts while i'm sleeping and i find
that not only do i dream much more happy
dreams i sleep much better and i wake up
feeling so much better the next day so
tonight when you're in bed and you have
your eyes closed make those last
thoughts that you think of a positive
thing it could be something like you're
being hopeful for the next day and
you're picturing in your mind how
awesome it's going to be but just
practice gratitude you'd be surprised
how awesome and what a calming effect it
can have on you don't knock it till you
try it all right enough about nighttime
routines how do you actually wake up at
5am feeling glorious
have you ever been so excited about
something that you couldn't sleep the
night before or you kept waking up
through the night because you thought it
was time to get up that's because when
you have a reason for why you're waking
up early or a motivation your brain
wakes up with a rush of happy hormones
that give you that boost of energy that
you need to get your butt out of bed you
have to romanticize the idea of waking
up early basically trick your brain into
seeing it as a pleasing thing to do or a
habit that you enjoy so ask yourself why
you're doing it to begin with what's
your purpose what do you plan on doing
have a clear picture in your mind for
the next day i can't tell you the number
of times i woke up early without having
a plan for the next day and you know
what i ended up doing when that happened
yeah going back to bed because i had
nothing to do
fail don't do this have a plan in place
for the next day another tip that i have
for you is to include something in that
plan that is specifically for your
enjoyment this is what james clear calls
habit stacking and basically what that
is is taking a habit that you already do
enjoy and pairing that with the habit
that you're trying to adopt that is not
enjoyable so for example if you're
waking up early to do taxes and you are
totally not excited about that then pair
that with something that you do enjoy
and this could be something as simple as
having an extra 10 minutes to get your
winged liner looking pristine having a
breakfast that you enjoy for me it's
lattes matcha latte chai latte cafe
latte i love me all things latte there's
just something cozy about a latte in the
morning that just brings me joy and it
brings a bit of yay to my morning so
find what those things are for you and
add them to your morning routine this
will help you actually enjoy waking up
early because it's more about you and
what you get to do
[Music]
and finally the day of here's some
things to consider first let's talk
about your alarm because the alarm that
you use can have a huge impact on how
you start your day that obnoxious loud
buzzing alarm never fails to wake me
with anxiety my heart rate shoots up and
instantly i start my day with stress
yeah that is not the right ringtone for
me you can try nature sounds a slow rise
that just slowly gets louder as time
progresses or if you're guilty of
pressing the snooze one too many times
then the math app can be your savior
basically what this does is that it
forces you to do puzzles before you can
turn off the alarm and this kind of
wakes up your brain whether you want it
to or not but whatever alarm that you
choose make sure that a it wakes you up
and b
it doesn't scare the heck out of you if
for whatever reason you still decided to
keep your alarm next to you maybe you
don't want to wake someone else up i
highly recommend mel robbins technique
and that is to count backwards from five
four three two one and just like a
rocket blast out of bed and what this
does is it basically forces you to act
before your brain can even react because
let's face it your brain will just tell
you to sleep in those first few seconds
are where you meet the most resistance
so as soon as your feet are on the
ground just know the hard part is over
with and you did it so now go hydrate
yourself splash some cold water on your
face go make yourself a latte and
conquer your day that is it for today's
video i thank you so much for watching
and if you liked this video and found it
helpful please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so you won't miss when i post
a new video and let me know what are you
going to do with your morning routines i
can't wait to hear from you in the
comments and see you in the next video
bye for now
[Music]